[Music]  what is it's very humanely what is it  take what is it to be alive  [Music]  it's person you speak to has had a day  some of the days have been good some bad  [Music]  each person you speak to has had a  childhood each has a body each body has  aches  look for what is special about each  individual focus on that  [Music]  remember there is someone out there for  everyone I think you're extraordinary  why I don't know yeah it's just obvious  to me that you are  [Music]  our time is limited we forget that  [Music]  sorry I grabbed your hand yes okay it's  a reflex  but I don't like to fly I said it's okay  can let go now though  [Music]  music ready play  [Music]